mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
bis los wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
die wechseljahre der frau
fluch oder sie körperliche veränderungen
dazu die angst vor dem unsichtbar werten
in der gesellschaft aber auch in der
kultur
klar doch frauen erkennen heute die
möglichkeiten des neuen lebensabschnitts
wird energie frei nutzen
eine bestandesaufnahme zu risiken und
nebenwirkungen der wechseljahre aber
ganz besonders zu den chancen
[Musik]
aus
von k
[Musik]
sie kommen auf den kulturplatz ja kaum
eine phase im leben einer frau ist mit
so vielen negativen klischees besetzt
wie die wechseljahre
damit wollen wir aufräumen denn diese
zeit im leben einer frau kann eine große
positive verwandlung sein privat wie
beruflich und darüber spreche ich gleich
mit der schauspielerin barbara terporten
hier im zürcher hotel kreuz
stöhr ist auch kreatives folgekrankheit
alles drum frage ich dich jetzt das frei
raus die wichtigste frau des antik wie
alt bist um 7.40 mit 50 öfter sehr
schlecht er jetzt haben wir das schon
mal transparent gemacht ja beantworten
kann einmal als bühnenschauspielerin aus
filmschauspielerin und osttirol vom
bestatter du bist die schönste
niederlage meist aber die dampf schaffen
und auch wird in einem zusammen
der staat versucht etwas gemeinsam
jugendzentrum bist doch wenn so kriegst
du ja so gut
stipe
ich muss hersteller fest
[Musik]
programm ein tiroler jetzt nur
überkommene 40 maschinen immer aber
empfehle ich glaube ich mir einfach
nicht so gut könnte 6 aber der mann
geschlafen und so gut gibt es im plan b
wenn man weiß als belegen dass ich
irgendwann vorbei
ja das hat nicht gemacht ich weiß das
wird schwierig diese große rolle sie die
werde mich nicht wieder besetzt und ich
habe mir stand bei als regisseurin und
bot im theater allerdings sehr klug
[Musik]
eine andere frau
bio ist fotografin marion kluge
sie hat jetzt gefordert per post an
inszeniert oder genau das ist kein mist
für das kursbild das mitglied abholt und
möglichst rasch und sie sich dass jene
vergessen dass die fotografiert werden
ganz viele bilder von starken frauen hat
vor ihnen ein buch das neue 40 alles
kann nichts muss wirklich als anblick
vor starken frauen sie haben sie alle
fotografiert was ist statement vor dem
buch sich das buch freiheit von vielen
reichten von extreme sind vor ort und
zeigen ob jetzt gesichtslosen wahnsinnig
viel
toll ist auch passieren es geht ja darum
ich glaube der fotografie das frauenbild
ist immer aus auch hier ist als
abziehbilder als klischees pilz hat viel
mit sexismus so wie schaffen wir da
wirklich einen schritt weiter zu
zufall oder reduzieren mit jedem doch
weg im zweifelsfall würde ich nicht
kritisieren also ich persönlich vom
falter mit diesen wahnsinnig schön und
ich bin voll besetzten jugendliche
schönheit ist komplett anders und ich
finde das muss man nicht vergleichen und
nicht gegen sie spielen sondern sich bis
heute und lastern unbedingt
dann können
als junge frau oder soll die frau bitte
sexy sein aus mutter voller liebe und
fürsorglichkeit und dann mit den
wechseljahren haben sie unsichtbar
werden soweit die klischees von
vorgestern
und wie ist das wirklich hier unser
stand der dinge hat freut das wirklich
zu hause in blüte tetra mit mini mini
zieht und jede wahl ist sondern um ein
taxi
da wird energie frei so da ist also eine
zeit des umbruchs die wahnsinnig
schwierig ist und so war das bei mir
auch und es war die fuß und ich wusste
nicht mehr wo oben und unten ist
[Musik]
begriffe befasst sich mit der salbe mit
denen körper mit einem schlecht geht
körper nicht jede frau erlebt die jahre
vor und nach der menopause individuell
schriftstellerin milena moser
journalistin silke buhrmester
psychologin pascalina peric und
gynäkologin china delhis sind sich aber
in einem punkt einig wir müssen über das
klimakterium regel viel zu lange wurde
der rapide hormon abbau bei der frau
tabuisiert
aus scham unwissenheit wegen
gesellschaftlicher normen erziehung
religion
viele haben angst nicht mehr
begehrenswert zu sein da wertlos während
in anderen kulturen frauen mit den
wechseljahren aufgewertet werden also
die dann auf einmal reif sind für ist
das mal so was wie den ältestenrat
diedorf führung oder was auch immer
findet bei uns eben eine entwertung
statt
deshalb hat silke buhrmester vor acht
monaten palais flux ins leben gerufen
eine online plattform auf der frauen ab
47 sich kreativ einbringen texte
verfassen und austauschen können
es ist eine form von selbstermächtigung
und dieser gedanke zu sagen okay wenn
die gesellschaft entscheiden welcher
nicht mehr auf uns richtet tun wir es
eben selbst ist genau das das ist das
was ich brauche damit irgendwie das
gefühl also ich komme aus der opferrolle
raus ich muss da nicht denken und die
anderen die sind jetzt sie wollen mich
nicht mehr sehen sondern ich denke
machen weshalb selbst und das ist gut
die wechseljahre sind in aller munde
dank emanzipation mehr selbstbewusstsein
und der aussicht auf ein langes leben
sind frauen bereit intimes zu teilen vor
zehn jahren beginnen milena moser mit
severin noch fast tabubruch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die juden
im zuge der wechseljahre der heißen
jahre wagte moser einen radikalen
neustart
sie wanderte in die usa aus wo sie sich
mit 51 unsterblich verliebte in die
schweiz reist sie nur wenn sie das will
natürlich wird immer mehr nicht sauber
in ihr drin der ganz klaren kompass
stimmt das für mich kann ich das will
ich das kann ich nun schlägt wieder
arbeit ich traue mir so viel mehr zu ich
mache mir experiment ich probier zu den
mittleren lebensjahren hat die
psychologin pascalina peric geforscht
auch für sie ist klar die wechseljahre
sollten als entwicklungsphase
wahrgenommen werden neudefinierung und
neupositionierung der stehen an
als entwickler von der eigenen stand
jetzt hat der eigene dimension in der
ersten hälfte ganz stark dominiert ist
vom gedanken sich in der gesellschaft
vor ort der gesellschaft patient und
seine landes medikament ist frage ist ja
wo bin ich selbst geblieben
das ist das was ich den auch mut machen
will dass du im prinzip nach den
wechseljahren bist du eine bessere
version von mir selbst
damit der weg dahin nicht qualvoll wird
selbst die ökologin himmel und hölle in
bewegung der nebst wallungen kann das
klimakterium auch chronische
schlaflosigkeit bis hin zu depressionen
bedeuten sila delhis empfiehlt jeder
frau den hormon abbau auszugleichen auf
einem niedrigen niveau
mit ihrem buch women on fire löst sie
eine hitzige debatte aus also monaten
heißt ja gibt in dem bewusstsein vieler
menschen
und das soll man mir nicht machen und
mehr das nimmt es ja irgendwie schwach
nur der held ja nichts aus der ist der
kapituliert sozusagen für den wechsel ja
aber das ist das ist falsch diese
vorstellung ist falsch es ist es ist
nicht nur unnötig so sehr zu leiden ist
es sogar ungesund also man weiß dieser
hormon defizit bereitet wirklich den
boden für ganz ganz ganz ganz viele
alterskrankheiten vor und mittlerweile
nimmt man körper identische hormone
das sind hormone in die exakte ex sagte
kopien sind von dem was der körper
früher hergestellt hat und deswegen ist
sie für den körper nicht belastbar oder
belasten
ich finde es ein bisschen schwierig denn
wir reden über einen natürlichen prozess
nun leben wir in einer gesellschaft die
sich immer mehr von natürlichen
prozessen entfernt ist ist so es ist so
vorgesehen es hat seinen sinn und meine
aufgabe ist damit klar zu kommen
am tour sind natürlich humorist natur ja
schlangen bist du signatur 119 ist natur
also alles ist natur aber wenn tour ist
nicht unbedingt gut kommt ist ein
fürchterlicher krankheit diabetes ist
fürchterlich franke aber wachsam sind
teil vom la vie pubertät und kopfschutz
weder reflektoren wieder mit de würden
sie ausgleichen oder wenn sie zum arzt
gehen würde wenn sie blut abnehmen und
sagen oh ich hab mich mit vitamin d ich
nehme jetzt wieder wenn die immer ein
vitamin d-spiegel anzuheben und so macht
man das mit den hormonen auch studie
und problem mit der körperlichen
umstellung ein drittel wieder das
spezielle und es entwickelt
jetzt wisst ich nicht wieso das man denn
alle die frau war es der kamm scheren
und medikamentös behandelt
es gibt tatsächlich ein drittel der
frauen die sagen ich habe keine
hitzewallungen aber was haben sie denn
noch haben sie gelenkschmerzen sagen ja
aber ich glaube ich habe irgendwie heime
und die mutter und der vater auch und
aber was ganz viele nicht wissen
tatsächlich 25 prozent der frauen haben
gelenkschmerzen als einziges symptom in
den wechseljahren also die meisten
frauen die sagen sie haben nichts haben
doch irgendwas wenn man lange fragt
praktisch null
ich sag ja auch nicht mein weg ist der
königsweg für alle sowie geht es darum
frauen aufzuklären damit sie einfach
wissen dass sie auktionen haben
aufklärung kommunikation
selbstbestimmung die gebote der stunde
ein bewusster umgang mit den
wechseljahren birgt die chance der
persönlichkeits findung und damit neue
perspektiven für die gesellschaft dass
man neue vorbilder für die nachfolgende
generation als sehr hilfreich sind
na dann willkommen wechseljahre
[Musik]
na wie geht's denn die ideen oder
fordern viel beschworene wachse ja ich
überhaupt schon drin
tja wenn ihr das willst mir geht's gut
wirklich sehr gute energie aber ich
möchte so dass mir natürlich und
ungeschickt gemacht wurden wenn du
morgen ist den verbund mich hast du dir
vorstellen dass es weitergeht was man
macht sich also gewisse gedanken bin ich
bereits um hormone wenn es mal
schlechter ist das no-go grundsätzliche
frage wo ich zuvor beschäftig bevor mit
hitzewallungen man sie über haben sind
ja klischee sehen nachdem ich glaube
dass ich habe bisher individuell sind
das zehn monate verurteilt muss glaubt
jede frau für sich und findet das muss
sowieso jeder mensch zu finden was für
gesunde und gut ist's egal von meist
über sport über alles und dir
hinterfragen dieser treffer oder was tut
mir gut aber ich würde wahrscheinlich
bis machen wenn ich merke jetzt wirklich
in mir depression und wird nur dass das
mehr möglich wieder gut geht dann ist
das sicher legitim oder wenn man sich
nimmt
die kreisstelle und ich habe es erlebt
und wenn man ein problem hat dann gilt
also plötzlich als unfrei oder was das
natürlichste der welt wieso hast du das
nicht und und somit jetzt andere erlaubt
und die finde das ist einfach nicht da
sondern für urteile geht das ist ganz
wichtig und spreche ich ja den eigenwert
mit anderen frauen darüber geredet wenn
man sich hilfe geholt und je mehr
miteinander zu tun hat und froh
solidarisch miteinander reden wie ist
spd und wie man auch studios unter
harmlos probieren um so einfach und man
viele studie zieht also ich erlebt dass
man unter freunden wirklich hat
repariert ist krass richtig und kraß
folgen und das darf nicht vorurteile und
darum sehr wichtig was man für die
mahlzeit oder also wie es mittags sie
was hätte gemacht gericht ist ein
ähnlich wie ein oder an war man sich
schützt oder die
was hast du für rollen im wallis ja als
hat einerseits natürlich minimiert
andererseits bin ich nach logischen
schulen und die kapazität kürzung
studiere ich spannende sachen küsst über
philosophie psychologie
ja das ist absolut okay aber aber doch
eher richtig und ich denke das ist ein
ko ländern mit 50 genauso sache war
schon krass machen kasse und natürlich
welche nicht absehen oder so nicht
trocken da hat ist ihr volz mit dem
blues man muss allerdings zu der
generation und sagen dass sie natürlich
nicht so unterstützt von einem mann wie
mir hört das ist modern bord und hilft
mit und und das schiff familie wird
zusammengeführt
hoffentlich in vielen fall und das ist
natürlich ja das ist entlastend oder
jetzt bist du immer brav und alters die
routine was sie nicht tun das hat sich
mit ihrer vita über das rathaus erst
haben aber noch zwei andere
berufskolleginnen vor der pubertät orten
wo man zu dem thema befragt hat rachel
braunschweig 53 jahre alt schauspielerin
aus zürich wo sie auch heute mit ihrer
familie lebt adrian andere ecken 52
jahre alt schauspielerin wohnhaft in
basel und hamburg
zwei frauen die gegen die sogenannte
alltagskriminalität braunschweig im film
marian andere ecken im theater sie ist
über 50 sie ist eine frau und sie hat
einen beruf der älterwerden nicht
verzeihen age on stage nimmt sich andere
in ihrer eigenen biografie an
auch im hinblick aufs altwerden als
schauspielerin
hier verschwinden schauspielerinnen bei
besten wetter
an der künstlerinnen das ist ein
business denkt stück extrem so gedanken
und mein gedanke darin vorkommen und
kritik ist hat natürlich eindeutig dass
er frauen zwischen 40 oder ende vierzig
bis sechzig verschwinden
marian andere kennt versteht es ihre
themen auf die bühne zu bringen und
verschafft sich durch ihren
intelligenten witz gehört theater machen
um gesehen zu wird warum warum warum der
theatermacher also wenn es so langsam
gott erstens willi kollegin von mir
wohnen im alter.de handys gehört das
mache mit ganz merkwürdige ängste und
ihre funde da machen nötig wird krank
also ich mache angst frage wo die sie
und ich hab natürlich wahnsinnig süß wie
wenn man älter ist muss man doppelt so
gut sie wenn man unsere unterschicht
grund wie ich muss man auch noch mal
dort zu kurz ich muss als frau muss man
noch mal doppelt zu kurz das macht drei
mal doppelt das muss man zwölf war so
wird sie zwölf mal besser sein oder
verschwinden rachel braunschweig denkt
nicht daran sich verschwinden zu lassen
passiert stattdessen lieber zum
shooting-star für ältere männer normal
für frauen die ausnahme und sicher auch
filme von der gesellschaft und und
verwertet alt hat eine innere
entscheidung sage ich bin da ein ganzes
leben im alter und die geschichte wohl
ich verkörpere sind erzählenswert und
das gefühl
seit wenigen jahren steht sie als
schauspielerin hoch im kurs
den publikumsrennern wie die göttliche
ordnung und the practice wieder
wolkenbruchs wunderliche weise als
katharina von zimmern in zwingli oder
als staatsanwältin im schweizer tatort
sind im aktuellen kinofilm spagat hat
braunschweig ihre erste hauptrolle
lehrerin marina lebt zufrieden mit
ehemann und tochter auf dem markt denn
unterhält sie eine liaison mit dem vater
einer ihrer schülerinnen besonders
heikel der ukraine lebt ohne papiere in
der schweiz
[Musik]
ich kann dir das spiel brachte
braunschweig spielt die marina
eindringlich glaubhaft und damit alle
gegen die wand das drehbuch schrieben
zwei junge männer mitte dreißig einer
von ihnen führte regie preis alles
warum
zum wettkampf zu speziellen jörg
unsichtbarkeit sieht anders aus und zu
alt gilt für rachel braunschweig nicht
ich bin da ich bin voller energie ich
bin voller lieder schafft filme für mich
so als die hälfte und ist viel hätte
jetzt noch mal so richtig aus brasov
super brachte braunschweig erzählt mit
ihren rollen geschichten die für alle
generationen und alle geschlechter
spannen sind und das will sie auch
weiterhin
adrian anda recken geht nicht den weg
des mainstreams und hat denn sehr viele
menschen einiges mitzuteilen sichtbar
und laut beide frauen sind veritable in
daegu keine späten sondern großartige
die ihrem weg in der zweiten hälfte des
lebens gehen und fahrer werden in bezug
aufs alter das merkt man natürlich schon
so viel im film er die fakten aber es
ist lang so wie ich habe vieles ändert
sich jetzt langsamer ich bin gegangen
das beispiel von der schwedische serie
wurden staatsanwalt im herzen graue
haare satz kommt denn blondiert die haut
was sagt mir dass über die rolle die das
etwas mit dem land jetzt verschiedene am
morgen kind und nachschaute irischer
fall wichtig die jetzt tritt sie zum
haus fahren und das finde ich total
spannend was man nach hause holen
engagierte kassierte faire bedingungen
für frauen im schauspiel mit dem verein
viel elektronik gründet hat ist das noch
immer als kampf gegen klischees oder was
ist vielleicht wirklich ständig und
diversität auf der bühne und empfehlen
und natürlich vertonen und jetzt bei mir
falsch ist kann man sagen natürlich ein
gewisses mischte und was heißt das es
muss ist wie das alter das ich habe der
mann den viele fouls zu alt ist die
wirken die mutter oder das ich schon
immer wieder gefragt wurde wo ich gerne
gassi also eine wurde mit seinem
motorrad aber das denn wiederum nichts
eltville teenager schwangerschaft aber
das sind dann so bildern vermittelt war
einfach eine zuschauerin überhaupt nicht
cool sind wenn man so eine junge mutter
und jetzt schon 20 jährige tochter war
aus über gut aus mit links haben das
sind einfach eine coole geschichte und
sich aufeinander ohne cool wenn sie ja
das ist das dann in die rollen wenn das
stimmt nicht mit mir
züge oder mit dem frauenbild über ihn ja
das stimmt ihr euch legend kampfparole
das ist ein theaterstück
die autorin unbedingt wurde das ist 73
sgb die bühne geht und wie so was ist so
schlimm daran dass ich okay jetzt kann
ich sagen 44 ware oder so was ist so
schlimm dran und das war für mich ein
grund richtig zum stritten und aussagen
auf der bühne und ich muss das für
körper und ich dort nicht so ich meine
spiele wenn ich jetzt mit wird er 50
jahre gespielt mit 47 ist nicht fair
es ist realität und wir sind zur sache
wo man darf erzählt meine geschichten zu
doof und in der realität sieht jedoch
viel spannender und anders und aber
treibe ich erwartet denn dadurch ein
spannendes und die männliche rolle tv
hin und weg sie ist mit dass man sie
jetzt mehr und so sollen zusammen
die gesellschaft besteht 15
[Musik]
zu diesem thema gebe ich ihnen gern noch
einen persönlichen tipp mit auf den weg
die weisheit der wechseljahre von der
amerikanischen ärzten christian in
nortrup ist für mich ein symbol dafür
dass wir diese lebensphase wirklich auch
aus große chance verstehen können ja
nächste woche da geht es bei uns um die
kreativität und gleich jetzt folgt auf
sf1 titanische serie die wege des herrn
küsste
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur ist
reese los
[Musik]